there's a really interesting sidebar
story to Robert Mahler's Trump Russia
investigation which is that the
investigation has turned a profit one of
the criticisms from Donald Trump and
from opponents of the investigation is
that it's a waste of money that it's
obviously a witch-hunt they say it's
obviously merely political they say some
say it's an illegal investigation and
it's crooked but they also have been
arguing that it's a waste of taxpayer
money so here's one example of that this
is a tweet from Donald Trump who said
quote ap has just reported that the
Russian hoax investigation has now cost
our government over 17 million dollars
and going up fast no collusion except by
the Democrats it turns out that it's not
a waste of money it's actually making
money the latest numbers according to
CNBC are that the Trump Russia
investigation have caught has cost about
twenty five million dollars it has
recovered 48 million dollars by virtue
of the tax evasion that it has revealed
this is just so brilliant in the process
of investigating criminality by Trump
associates and aides so much tax evasion
was discovered that they've recouped and
almost doubled the cost of the
investigation in total while finding
multiple criminals getting countless
guilty verdicts and pleas on record and
sending people to prison and this
relates to a bigger issue which is that
in general the IRS targets people for
audit in part based on who is likely to
be worth auditing what do I mean by that
if you make under a hundred thousand
dollars for example you're much less
likely to be audited because not not
necessarily because you're less likely
to cheat on your taxes but because if
you have cheated the Delta the amount
that might be recovered is much smaller
let's say you made under a hundred
thousand dollars and underpaid your
federal taxes by 10% that's going to be
an amount that is far exceeded by the
cost of auditing you so with Trump and
his associates there are so many rich
tax cheats surrounding Trump that in
just the normal course of running the
Trump Russia investigation Moeller found
48 million dollars
almost doubling the cost of the
investigation so number one Pat it turns
out that this has been a great
investment Trump can't find money for
the wall Mexico won't pay for it the
House and Senate won't pay for it the
taxpayers don't want to
Moeller found a way to make all of
trumps criminal cronies pay for the
investigation that he's doing and that's
all fun and we're having a grand old
time with it but there's a really
important point here to be made that I
don't want to get lost in the fun and
games of Muller doubling the cost of the
investigation with recouped tax under
payments investigating the criminal
wrongdoing and possible conspiracy by
the president and his associates is
serious even if it costs 25 million and
recovered nothing it would still be
worth it because we spend 25 million on
you know a few missiles that we decide
to drop here or there around the world
so on the one hand Pat it's good to push
back when the right says the
investigation is a waste of money and
say actually the investigation has made
money but we shouldn't allow that to
cloud the reality that with all the
money we waste a good investment is
figuring out if the president of the
presidency by criminality and conspiracy
I totally agree because we have to know
if our president is a crook typically
when you talk about government
expenditures at the federal level you're
talking about numbers that are in the
billions and even taking Trump out of
his words 17 million dollars that's
really not that much money especially if
you consider all the resources that you
think have to go into an investigation
like this all the people that you have
to pay all the stuff that you have to
try to dig up making a financial
argument over the
is just not something that's gonna hold
up that's right it's the wrong argument
to make and it just so happens as a
bonus that this is turning out to be
quite profitable for the US government
but you're not going to hear that from
those who insist that it's an illegal
witch hunt investigation a witch hunt
which by the way has found which is
under just about every Rockets looked
under